[Música]
economía en directo américa de france 24
conmigo en el estudio de luis mendez
zurich elvis ya terminamos esta semana
cargada de información no china estaría
comprando más petróleo a rusia que está
pasando así se desprende de una
publicación de la agencia noticias
roiter es un tema que está bajo la
atención mundial porque a juicio de esta
empresa de información china habría
aumentado la compra de petróleo ruso
durante la invasión a ucrania china
considerado como el principal importador
de petróleo en el mundo de acuerdo con
el reporte habría tomado la decisión un
mes después de haber recortado la compra
de hidrocarburos a rusia como una bebida
para evitar sanciones a sus principales
empresas petroleras pero de acuerdo con
el medio la importación se incrementaría
a un millón cien mil barriles diarios en
el mes de mayo esto es 350 mil barriles
más de lo que había importado en el
primer trimestre y 300 mil barriles
diarios más que él diariamente durante
el año 2021 reuters revela que esta
situación le ha permitió a rusia
compensar el retiro de algunos
compradores que han dejado de adquirir
el petróleo ruso por temor a sanciones y
se pregunta entonces qué países se
pudieran ver afectados por esta medida
de acuerdo con reuters esta situación se
presenta por el interés de china de
adquirir petróleo a un precio menor y
que estaría a unos 29 dólares por debajo
del precio que ostentaba el producto al
inicio de lo que fue llamada la
operación militar de rusia ahora
respecto a tu pregunta quien estaría
limitando las compras de irán y de
venezuela dos países que además de ser
socios comerciales de china también
están sancionados por eeuu como lo está
rusia en estos momentos pasamos ahora
italia leaks porque allí se empieza a
sentir el principal efecto de la guerra
en el aumento de todos los precios no
así es porque de acuerdo con los últimos
datos de la nación la inflación en ese
país presentó una reducción de 0,1 punto
porcentual a nivel mensual en el mes de
abril pero se ubicó en puntos
porcentuales a nivel interanual es decir
en el mismo período pero del año
anterior adicionalmente la cifra del ipc
armonizado
presentó un alza de 0.4 puntos
porcentuales a nivel mensual y se ubicó
en 63 por ciento interanual pero bien
los efectos de la guerra que entre otras
cosas han provocado un aumento en los
precios de la energía y los combustibles
han presionado los precios en italia un
país que alcanzó un ipc armonizado de 68
por ciento durante el mes de marzo
siendo este el dato más alto desde que
la nación se sumó al euro como moneda
común entre los alimentos el precio del
pescado el trigo y otros han mostrado un
mayor incremento como consecuencia del
aumento en los costos de producción y
distribución por escuchemos uno de los
análisis que hacen los italianos
respecto a esta situación
yo creo que si se ofreció concreto que
la inflación aumentará aunque sean
civilmente porque el banco central y si
sólo falte probar probablemente un buen
prepárate creo que existe el riesgo de
que la inflación pueda aumentar aún más
porque los bancos centrales
probablemente no estaban preparados con
tasas de interés muy bajas en un
contexto posterior a la pandemia donde
los gobiernos han aumentado el gasto
público esto provocó un aumento en la
demanda lo que generó un aumento en los
precios y a esto se suma a la guerra en
ucrania que trajo consigo una fuerte
contracción en la oferta de gas petróleo
y trigo convenía restricciones de la
oferta allí
gas petróleo grano les cambiamos de tema
porque canadá prohibido la participación
de la empresa china huawei en el
desarrollo de su plataforma 5g y es la
manera canadá según a países como reino
unido estados unidos australia y nueva
zelanda que ya anunciaron la imposición
de sanciones a esta empresa es el
anuncio fue hecho por el ministro de
industria canadiense
françois film champagne quien indicó que
la decisión se tomó tras una revisión
completa por parte de las agencias de
seguridad escuchemos el y que comisión
compañías en canadá
primera de las empresas de
telecomunicaciones en canadá no podrán
incluir en sus redes productos o
servicios que pongan en riesgo nuestra
seguridad nacional los proveedores que
tengan estos equipos deberán dejar de
usarlos y retirarlos según los planes
que anunciamos hoy en mi móvil audio de
plans williams / the lizzie que nos
tiene como cifra el día para finalizar
este primer bloque económico en directo
américa tiene que ver en este caso con
la visita que está haciendo el
presidente yo va a ir en a corea del sur
y específicamente a la empresa samsung
donde está va a invertir en eeuu la
cantidad de 17.000 millones de dólares
para el desarrollo de una planta en
austin recordemos que parten está
interesado en producir más chips de
semiconductores así es y la esposa de
joe biden jill biden también está de
gira y lo vamos a hablar con nuestro
corresponsal en panamá